how does the end scene for you go where
are you going in that in that moment the
the last scene between Nick and Fanny is
um
it really really really personally rocks
me just I understand so well
the Heartbreak of that goodbye
and um are you pulling I mean I don't
have to pull it's just coming
um because I pull I don't feel like I
know how to fake things I pull from real
life oh I did oh that yes yes yes
um and you don't have to say it but like
I when I'm
crying in a scene I'm thinking about my
dad oh yeah I'm thinking about loss I'm
thinking about stuff are you even
talking about it now it just comes right
up I'm not like I'm gonna cry because
the scene calls for it yeah I go there
you go there of course I mean I have a
whole bag of things I could pull from
it's like what are we going to use today
um yeah and and it's it's this Arc it's
this it's this extreme sense of loss
it's this you know and when she looks in
the mirror during funny girl and she's
just you know did you hear that funny
like that's that's all you are you're
just this this funny girl and
when you're a funny girl like you just
you got to be tough and you have to take
what people throw at you and I certainly
get that
but then she says I guess we didn't make
it well at least I didn't fake it at
least I held my ground at least I gave
it everything
and then it's like okay
you think it's over
but we are gonna pick ourselves up right
now
we're gonna dig down deep to that
strength that is somewhere in there and
we're gonna go and that's what I do and
she says now we begin no looking back
you know stiff upper chin let's give him
hell and right now I am so grateful to
look towards this future this
opportunity
um my family and and that's where my
head is at and um and right now I am
grateful to
play this role to sing these songs it's
it it's such a part of me this character
and and and her
that I'm just so grateful the moment is
the opportunity to just truly perform
and to give what I can give to the
audience and bring people to the theater
I'm just so yeah thank you
I'm just so grateful to be able to you
know
bring people to the theater speaking
speaking of I'm watching you yeah you're
at the beginning of the show
and in your very first few minutes of
the show yep you mentioned the Barrymore
yes I do and I wrote the minute
here we are on September 6th the opening
night and I'm so nervous and I'm singing
greatest star and I'm like
and that's six Expressions mod and all
the Barry mods put together and I was
like oh my God Drew's here I remember
it's you it's your family it's your
legacy in funny girl that was written
you know so many years ago I mean that's
what a full circle wild moment it made
me feel very confident about that this
is the shirt exactly it's sober shared
it really is it's it's these moments
that I'm I'm so magnetized to where
you're at now thanks and I I don't
believe I know this is your moment and
am I safe to say yes you are pulling
from everything in your life and putting
it for real into the show that audiences
when they come here are knowing this is
your heart soul life experience and
Truth
I'm giving everything I really am I'm
not leaving anything so I'm leaving it
all on the stage every single night and
day how are you gonna keep this going I
don't know how you didn't go back home
and say okay I did it after opening
night I got that out of my system I
nailed it I stuck The Landing thank you
this is drama this is tears this is
vulnerability this is strength and if I
don't look and feel the way Fannie Bryce
does and we are not unattractive women
but I don't look at those tall show
girls and ever feel like I belong I'm
the clown yeah
well I mean it's it's wild it's it's you
know when I before I even did Glee like
I was always told there there's not a
place for you on television you don't
fit in in that world and it's funny how
people sort of create these narratives
so what do you say to those women who
have got the goods we can bring it we're
not the tall show Girls we might even be
the clown and yet somehow we're
headlining how does this happen
I've seen such a shift since like I
started with Glee in just
how much more
I just how it's opened up for those
funny girls out there and I'm just
grateful to be one of them with all due
respect to the past and all the people
who have loved this will shine in this
role from Barbra Streisand on
I think this is your part I think this
is I think you will be the marker and
you earned it you have
out in the Marquee and announce what's
going on
did you see that they just put my
picture up out there and I haven't seen
it oh yeah well let's take the should
catch it
[Music]